it is seven o'clock good to see you this
morning and we start the day with the
news that tens of thousands of nurses
are striking today and the biggest
action of its kind in NHS history picket
lines have been set up at dozens of
hospitals across England Wales and
Northern Ireland thousands of NHS
appointments and routine operations
canceled all in a dispute over pay and
patient safety we will be live on the
picket line this morning speaking to
nurses we'll also hear from the head of
the union and the health Minister Maria
colfield it is Thursday 15th of December
tens of thousands of nurses go on strike
over pay in the first national walkout
in the Union's history
the head of the Royal College of nurses
warns there could be further strikes in
the New Year if the government doesn't
negotiate
calls for Urgent action after a small
boat sank in the English Channel
yesterday at least four people died 39
were rescued
continued overnight
I'm live in sangata's French and British
officials say the incident is a stark
reminder of the need to destroy the
Smuggler's business model
the bank of England is Secretary's
interest rates again today for the ninth
time in the world
thousands of people in Shetland face a
fourth day without power as Engineers
battle to restore the supply knocked out
by heavy snow
[Music]
foreign all members of the Royal College
of Nursing are beginning their first
national strike in the Union's 100 Year
history this morning
there's tens of thousands of nurses walk
out across England Wales and Northern
Ireland in the disputes overpay and
working conditions well this means a
bank holiday style service in many areas
with some routine operations and
appointments canceled but nurses will
still provide Urgent Care the health
secretary Steve Barkley says he's
concerned about the risk strikes posed
to patients but the union has warned
that unless the government negotiates
well there are likely to be further
walkouts in January let's take a look at
the action today in just a little bit
more detail and as many as a hundred
thousand nurses will walk out for 12
hours in England Wales and Northern
Ireland strikes not going ahead in
Scotland when a deal has been done
76 trusts will be affected that's around
a quarter of trust in England all but
one in Wales and every trust in Northern
Ireland
uh well the Royal College of Nursing the
RCN is calling for an above inflation
pay increase which well as you can see
currently works out at 19.2 they do say
though they're willing to negotiate
the government says that figure well it
is unaffordable their most recent
payoffer was an increase of at least
1400 pounds which works out to be an
average uplift of around about four
percent
now as many as 20 70 000 appointments
and operations could have been canceled
today now that is mostly routine care
such as knee and hip replacements and
Community nursing less unwell patients
attending a e and what they've been told
they will be waiting longer than usual
but Services protected includes
intensive and Critical Care Emergency
cancer Services children's a d and
neonatal units with NHS bosses urging
people to use Emergency Services as
normal
we've been working for months in order
to reduce the disruption for patients so
obviously there will be some disruption
from the industrial action but our aim
all the way through is to be with to
work with the unions in order to
minimize that disruption and I really do
have to emphasize that patients should
use the Emergency Services as normal
uh we will of course be bringing you the
latest from the picket lines in a few
months time but first our political
correspondent Tamara Cohen joins us in
the studio good to see you this morning
tomorrow look can we just talk about the
realities of the negotiation or lack
thereof we understand the RCN was
looking for slightly above 19 the
government is sticking to the
independent peer reviews recommended
roughly four percent or thereabouts they
didn't have to stick to that did they
the government have insisted that they
have to take the independent pay reviews
recommendations which works out as you
say about four and a half percent across
the board but it is more for some of the
lower paid nurses but they are now faced
with the first Nationwide strike this is
England Wales and Northern Ireland not
in Scotland for a century
um 44 NHS trusts that's about a third of
those in England voted to strike reached
all the required thresholds which is
quite a high bar at the moment and yet
the health secretary and the
government's view is that they were not
going to compromise even though the
nurses Union having asked for something
um very big 19 pay increase indicated
strongly particularly last weekend that
they might accept something lower but
potentially what the nurses were offered
in Scotland which is about seven and a
half percent which is still above what
the independent review recommended but
ministers have dug in the nurses Union
say that the health secretary would not
talk to them about pay they had a couple
of meetings with him but they were all
focused on the other issues that the
nurses are striking over to do with
working conditions that he would not get
into pay negotiations with them and
therefore they say they were left with
no choice but to go on this strike but
the the concern is there'll be another
one on Tuesday and there will is already
talk of more in the New Year
again just just to be absolutely clear
here the RCN signal at the weekend that
they would be willing to negotiate if
they had sat down and the conversation
had been about pay they weren't looking
for a deal necessarily but they were
looking for that conversation the
strikes would have been paused the
operations that have been canceled today
would have gone ahead the that's what
the nurses units say they say that that
is exactly what would have happened they
talked about Pat Cullen of the Union
talked about pressing the pause button
if the government were willing to
compromise she said they were willing to
compromise but at a final meeting with
Steve Barkley the health secretary at
the beginning of the week those talks
broke down because the government dug in
and you saw what the chancellor said
yesterday in response to the latest
inflation figures he basically indicated
that if um pay Rises across the public
sector reach the levels of inflation he
said and others dispute this it could
just feel further inflation so the
government digging in very hard but
there are already MPS conservative MPS
saying behind the scenes look we're
going to have to compromise somewhere
it'll be very interesting then to hear
the views of Maria colfield who of
course was was back working as a nurse
during covid she was a nurse before
going to politics specializing in cancer
and yes she did do shifts during the
pandemic so yes be interesting to hear
from her yep the minister will be on the
program in a few minutes time tomorrow
for no thank you at today's nursing
strikes of course just one part of a
suite of industrial action taking place
across different sectors this month
let's just remind you well after a 48
hour rail strike earlier this week real
workers will walk out again tomorrow on
Saturday and four days around Christmas
Mick Lynch due to be real bosses for
further talks today and see what happens
with that one
but as for the nursing strikes where we
can expect another one next Tuesday
which continues the first set of mass
strikes in the Royal College of
nursing's 106 year history
foreign
staff including paramedics Emergency
Care assistants and call handlers they
will all be striking on the 21st and the
28th
postal workers they continue their
48-hour strike today and another two-day
strike due 23rd 24th
one about border force staff now they
will be striking from the 23rd to the
26th and then again from the 28th to the
31st
and driving test examiners and some
civil servants they will also be going
on strike this month
uh but to some other news now and the
search has continued off the Kent Coast
overnight after at least four people
died when a digging carrying around 50
Asylum Seekers capsized in the English
Channel a warning these pictures show
the moment some of the survivors were
rescued which you may find distressing
39 people in fact were rescued after the
dinghy collapsed in freezing Waters many
of them saved by passing fishermen and
his crew a French charity says it
received this desperate message from
someone on the boat as the water came in
they've asked that we distort the voice
[Music]
they don't have anything for it
please help me bro please please please
we are on the water
um uh well let's speak to a couple of
our correspondents are your
correspondent Siobhan Robbins is in
songat in France for us this morning but
first uh let's speak to Ashley heranaki
joins us from Dover and Ashton just just
bring us up to the very latest what do
we know about what happened well just a
little over 24 hours ago
all that footage is absolutely harrowing
and you're right just over 24 hours ago
the temperature of the channel was
something like minus four degrees and
therefore that search and operate rescue
operation had to be called off
incredibly quickly and it quickly became
a recovery operation incidents like this
simply do not deter people some 5 000
pounds is what those people paid to be
on that overcrowded dinghy and we know
that much of it began to fill up with
water we understand the whole bottom of
that boat became saturated and therefore
Panic ensued it is calm Waters that
these people tend to take advantage of
and by people I mean the people
Smugglers but also those who are
desperately trying to come across and
seek Asylum since ever since the clamp
down on those coming across on trucks
this has become the made method of
trying to get into the UK illegally and
we know that not only do tragedies like
this happen all too often a missing's
migrants projects at her they found that
data they've collected showed 205 people
have been missing or dead in the channel
since 2014 yesterday four more added to
that tally they were brought ashore by
the um lifeguards from the rnli the
station of which is just behind me and
yesterday very late last night a private
ambulance was seen coming to collect
those people's bodies and taking them
away of course now the official
identification process has to begin
that's going to be incredibly difficult
often when these people board these
boats they're not coming across with any
official documentation they don't have
any passports and so it's going to be
incredibly difficult and Incredibly
challenging
for people to try and speak to these
people's families to let them know
what's happened but this is absolutely a
tragedy another reminder that making
this Crossing is incredibly dangerous
and often when these people get on those
boats it is a tragedy waiting to happen
thanks National let's bring in Siobhan
who's at San Gat and Siobhan I suppose
the question is is what authorities on
both sides of the channel no do I mean
it wasn't that long ago that both the
French and the British were were proudly
healing a closer working relationship
they're involved you know British
policemen being in the control rooms on
the French side
foreign
yes that's right so when this happened
yesterday we got a joint statement from
the British and French government
underlining again that they're working
together increased patrols for example
that they're working with European
Partners to try and Destroy This
smuggling network but it's a really
massive challenge it's not a matter of
just going in and raiding a few
Smugglers bases along this Coast it's an
international Network so for example in
Turkey I met people coming from Syria
that paid Smugglers money which they
held in Istanbul until those people got
to Serbia that money was then released
and pushed out into wider Smuggler
networks they then continued their
Journey maybe to France maybe to Germany
possibly coming here to cross to the UK
and smuggling networks work together so
for example people in Albania May pay a
local Albanian but then when they get
here that money will be released for
example to a Kurdish gang which then run
a lot of the boats that go across the
channel so it's a huge operation and the
other problem is not just busting the
smuggling rings but also remove moving
the the desire for people to take this
journey because although we focus a lot
on albanians if you take them out of the
picture from this year the other main
nationalities crossing the channel are
people from Afghanistan Syria Iraq for
example so people who are often running
away from war and they've done these
Journeys this is often the last leg on
it throughout the rest of the journey
they've crossed loads of borders they've
probably been beaten and extorted along
the Route they get here and they just
think well why not there is literally
nothing to lose and that's what
charities are saying they say they will
continue to make this Crossing unless we
can offer them a safe option to try and
get out of the danger that they're in
Siobhan ashnap thank you both very much
indeed much more on that story of course
throughout the day but still to come the
health Minister Maria colfield will be
in the studio with us in a few minutes
time to give us the government's view on
today's nursing strikes
and shortly after that we'll be speaking
to the head of the RCN Pat Cullen
joining us from the picket line
just after eight for their view Labor's
Shadow Justice secretary Steve Reed
but let's take a look at some of the
day's other headlines now and the bank
of England is expected to raise interest
rates again at lunchtime as the cost of
living continues to soar economists are
predicting the bank will increase its
base interest rate from three percent to
3.5 as it tries to combat inflation this
would represent the ninth consecutive
hike
rules around ticking liquids and laptops
through airport security will be relaxed
from June 2024 passengers at most UK
most major UK airports will be able to
carry containers up to two liters that's
20 times the current limit
and travelers won't be having to take
their laptops or their tablets out of
their hand luggage whilst going through
checkpoints
Boris Johnson has earned more than a
million pounds for species since he
resigned as prime minister just over
three months ago according to the latest
parliamentary records he has delivered
four speeches between October and
November since leaving dining Street the
best paid work was a speech to a U.S
Finance firm worth 277
000 pounds
more than 2 000 homes are facing a
fourth day without power in Shetland
after heavy snowstorms people there are
being urged to use warm hubs for hot
food and drink and rest Engineers from
Scottish and Southern electricity
networks are working to restore power to
the islands
sad on this police sub-expressed their
deepest sympathies to the family of a
six-year-old boy after it was confirmed
he'd become the fourth child to die
after falling into an icy lake in
solihull the boy had been in a critical
condition in hospital since the incident
at the weekend police announced the
deaths of the other three boys aged 8 10
and 11. on Monday
tick tock's algorithms have been
criticized for promoting videos about
self-harm and eating disorders
research by the center for countering
digital hate suggests the app recommends
potentially harmful content within
minutes of it being opened further
investigation by Sky News find evidence
of harmful eating disorder content being
recommended through suggested searches
Tick Tock well it's it's disputed the
fungals
and to the World Cup now and Morocco's
Fairy Tale run in Qatar is over
following a two-nil semi-final defeat to
the holders France
France are the first team to reach
back-to-back finals since Brazil 20
years ago they will be facing Argentina
in Sunday's finals
and I had a tenor on Morocco as well
let's return now to those unprecedented
strikes taking place in the health
service today uh with as many as a
hundred thousand nurses set to work out
joined by the health Minister Maria
Caulfield it's called lovely to see you
this morning
um
I I suppose this must be a tricky one
for you you very very recently were back
in the wards yourself working as a nurse
you know that this will have been a very
very difficult decision for them and I
suspect that there is a bit of you that
that knows that they have something of a
point
yeah so I mean it's with huge regret
that we're saying you know in England 44
of the 215 trusts uh going out on strike
today
um the same situation is in Wales where
all but one of the trusts there are
going out on strike in Northern Ireland
the government there are facing all of
their trusts so it is with regret and
absolutely we recognize that pay is an
issue that's why last year um nurses
were given a three percent pay rise with
no other public sector were and that's
why we accepted him for the
recommendation from the Independent pay
view body for this year of 4.8 percent
uh for most nurses but over nine percent
for those on the lowest bands
Steve Barkley we will talk about the
paid aspect in just a second but but
clearly people will be concerned about
service provision today and Steve
Barkley said that that he has concerns
about patients on a day like today where
exactly is he concerned what what are it
is so I think also you know some of the
the national nurse leaders so Ruth May
has wrote to the RCN about concerns as
well and they were pleased that the r10
did move on some of those uh uh
derogations for certain services but you
know cancer surgeries are going to be
closing those 44 trusts in England we
reckon it's about 70 000 appointments
procedures surgeries uh that will be
lost so that is going to have an impact
when the system is already struggling to
get through the covert let's not mean so
what's here when you see have an impact
you are suggesting that as a result of
nurses going out on strike today
patients will suffer that people will be
in pain and that Health outcomes May
diminish I think you know that that is
an inevitable action of strike action
and that's why it is with regret um that
you know we see that the RCN are going
out uh on on action today
um you absolutely understand uh the
issues around paying I've explained uh
what measures we took around that but
the secretary of state did meet with the
RCN earlier this week to talk about some
of the other factors that make life very
difficult for nurses on the front line
if Steve Barkley had sat down this week
with the nurses and discussed P not the
other things but discuss P the strikes
would have not have gone ahead today
well I don't necessarily agree with that
we can't uh do you think the RCN were
lying when they said if you sit down
with us and talk about P we will not
strike no I don't think that I don't
think that I know Pat Khan very well and
very a huge respect for Pat I don't
think they were lying but the demand of
19 is not um uh something we can
realistically uh deliver on each of the
immediate perfectly cleared at the
weekend that yep they had suggested 19
but that they would be willing to
negotiate they would even perhaps have
been willing to take that figure of 7.5
which has worked in Scotland which is
why they do not have nurses striking so
in Scotland they they have suspended
strikes but that deal hasn't been agreed
they've put that to their members the
RCN aren't actually recommending that
deal to their members and we won't know
the outcome of that till the 19th of
December so they're not striking off
they're not striking today but they
haven't resolved the dispute in full and
we have for every percent that we agree
for the nurses or for anyone else uh in
fact that's around 700 million pounds
that we have to find and as a government
there's only three ways we can find that
money well I have to borrow it and we
know the impact of borrowing when
governments can't afford it we saw that
just a few weeks ago you either have to
put taxes up for patients for patients
and why not waste 30 billion pounds on
on useless PPE I mean the thing I don't
think many people understand here is why
this government is absolutely rigid in
its claim that it has to stick to the
recommendations of the independent peer
review body I mean you don't the
recommendations you've ignored it in
various other Industries I mean the
police Federation pulled out of their
independent remuneration review body
back in 2021 because for years the
government had ignored the
recommendations of that body on that
occasion it was politically expedient to
ignore it I'm generally suggesting that
on this occasion it is politically
expedient for you to let the strikes go
ahead well I disagree we did accept the
recommendations because we recognize
that pay is an issue and as I said
that's 4.8 for the average nurses but
over nine percent for those on on the
lowest bands so we absolutely uh
recognize that and committed to that
info not just for nurses but across uh
the health recommendations in total
um yes we could uh you know they're not
legally binding we could uh override
that we freeze across the entire civil
service for a very long time that was
completely circumventing this
independent peer-of-view body process
which exactly makes my point that you
know we could have uh ignored the pay
review bodies recommendations and gone
for a much lower pay rise we didn't we
could go higher but as I've said we've
got to find that money from somewhere
this isn't government money this is
taxpayers money
um and the three options open to us if
we were to to have to to fund a higher
pay rise is either to borrow the money
tax people more or take that money from
Frontline service or listen to the
former conservative party chairman Jake
Berry who says the government is going
to have to improve its offer I can tell
you Mr Berry said that the government
offer is too low I mean the period of
your body recommendation came back in
the summer when when inflation was was
lower you knew inflation was on the rise
if you'd actually negotiated back then
you could have probably gotten away with
seven and a half percent well the pay
review uh body also negotiate with the
unions the unions are involved in that
process and at that time they they did
not raise concerns you know as you say
you know it was no secret that inflation
was on the rise and they accepted that
at that time the process for April is
starting already and the unions will be
involved in that process in terms of
making their their um their position
clear about what they would like to see
in next year's pay Rises to just be
absolutely clear from now until January
when we are expecting no more strikes by
the Royal College of Nursing the
government point-blank refuses to sit in
a room with the head of the RCN and
discuss P not necessarily have an offer
but discuss P well the sales actually
did discuss pay with the RCN on Monday
we haven't come to an agreement on that
which is is quite clear because we have
said you know the Prime Minister was
very clear on prime minister's questions
yesterday that that's uh he's accepted
the pay review bodies recommendations we
can't go to 19 that's unrealistic the
labor government in Wales also haven't
moved on that so the RCN themselves have
said they are willing to come down from
19 I I mean I don't know why we keep
getting government figures saying as if
both of your positions aren't completely
interactable both of you can move so for
that we we are health is a devolved
matter as you know so we can only
negotiate for England but we're also
seeing trust uh all but one of the
trusts in labor-run Wales also uh out um
on strike and in Northern Ireland so you
know this is a similar situation in uh
in the other devolved Nations as well
um and so you know it's absolutely
crucial that we do keep the door open to
talks because we want to talk but we
cannot afford that 19
I do need to talk to you about about the
events that took place in the channel
yesterday and I think for a number of
people this is a situation that is
happening time and time again there are
an increased number of people coming
across the channel this year as we hear
from swella bravaman which means that
there is an increased risk of death
everything this government has tried to
do to prevent deaths in the channel has
not worked isn't it finally time for for
the conservative party for the
conservative government to admit that
you have field that you have failed to
prevent preventable deaths in the
channel well I think the Prime Minister
was very clear in his statement to the
House of Commons this week setting out
his five-point plan you know it's the
day before this terrible tragedy in the
channel and our heart goes out to all of
those involved and to the emergency
services that had to respond uh to that
terrible event but the Prime Minister
was very clear he doesn't feel that
progress has been good enough
um he's you know it one of the things
he's highlighted is around clearing that
backlog by the end of uh next year
because it is taking too long to process
claims but also we do have to do more to
stop those Crossings across that is that
is the key point and I know I've got to
let you go in just a second but but
genuinely everything that this
government has tried has not worked
isn't it possibly time to to expand the
range of auctions try things that you
know this government for ideological
reasons has decided it could not push
forward such as or for example setting
up some ability for people to claim
Asylum without having to get in a small
boat and cross the channel so the Prime
Minister did that was one of his
recommendations as part of his plan to
to tackle this illegal immigration is to
open up safe illegal roots and he will
be having negotiations about that but
that is for genuine Asylum Seekers and
not for people who are coming here for
economic reasons and that's one part of
the whole process and he has said that
that's something he is looking at we'll
look forward to seeing what he has to
come up with I mean if you've got busy
days I'll let you go thanks thank you
now are people and politics
correspondent Nick Martin is in
Liverpool for us this morning on the
picket line in fact um Nick bring us up
to date what are people telling you
well it's a mix of determination to
stand their ground and a reticence that
they have to do this uh meal it's a cold
morning here in Aintree minus six
degrees and the nurses are preparing
their picket lines uh to go on strike as
we've heard it's a historic strike it
hasn't happened for more than a hundred
years and they should be in the
hospitals in the warmth of the wards
caring for patients but that is not the
reality and as we've just heard in that
interview uh discussions between the RCN
and the government have pretty much
ground to a halt if they ever really got
started and the head of the RCN Pat
Cullen today warning that uh if the
government don't start negotiating she
says that there will be more strikes
going into the new year the busiest time
for the NHS I just want to talk to a
nurse while we're here
um Carmel or Boyle who is the chair of
the Northwest branch of the RCN good
morning Carmel I mean how are you
feeling and what are your thoughts today
ahead of this strike morning and thanks
for coming to support us and this has
been a really difficult time it's been
very difficult to organize but as we've
already talked about before this has
been a horrible decision for nurses to
make it's not something that we ever
wanted to do and we hoped that Steve
Barclay would negotiate with us to to
call our health to this so we could talk
and have some meaningful negotiations
but that hasn't happened and we are
determined that we're going to fight for
our NHS and fight for our patients and
this is what we're doing today on our
picket lands well I was with you wasn't
I you know in October when your ballot
paper came through at your home and you
were signing it and there was a bit of
reticence about it but the fact is
though Carmel that there are thousands
of patients who will get a reduced
service today because nurses have chosen
these dates in the middle of a winter
crisis to go on strike
um I mean how do you feel about that
that's not ideal by any stretch is it
absolutely not let's say it's not
something that we wanted to do and you
saw us make those decisions but for
their operations and all kinds of things
being canceled today but those things
were canceled yesterday as well and they
will be tomorrow because there's not
enough of us any day in the NHS so I I
hate to say it but today is really no
difference we are stretched every single
day and we are overworked and
overburdened and we don't have enough
nests and this is what this is about
this is about getting a fair pay so that
we can recruit and retain more nurses
into the service so we can look after
our patients Carmel thanks so much I
really appreciate you taking the time to
talk to us this morning some services
are still running Critical Care
chemotherapy emergency Cancer Care
dialysis Pediatrics they're still
running but that still leaves a huge
swathe of the NHS which is effectively
on a sort of bank holiday service now
and it really comes down to the nurses
on strike today and hopes really that
the RCN and the government can get
together to try and avert any further
strike actions as we go deeper into the
winter Neal you know we will see won't
we Nick thanks for now
the cold weather I'm afraid it's set to
continue over the coming days with
yellow weather warnings for snow and ice
in place for parts of the country Sky
meteorologist uh Kirsty McCabe joins us
now good to see you this morning Kirsty
so so where should be concerned about
this continuing incredibly cold spell
well obviously we've heard the issues in
the Shetland Islands and there are more
wintry snow showers to come here with
quite moderate Breezies but across many
parts of the UK we've still got this
intense cold spell this morning sorry
it's minus six widely across the UK and
Ireland temperatures are Sub-Zero and I
took a look at some of the minimum
temperatures earlier so down to between
-9 to -12 and some of the coldest spots
parts of Wales Northwest England for
example so a bitterly called start this
morning and I think it's sunny bridge at
the moment the coldest place at -12 now
if we take a look at the weather
warnings as well today we've got snow
and ice around across parts of the north
and east so Northern and Eastern parts
of Scotland all the way down to the east
coast of England as well and parts of
Northern Ireland too I've got snow and
ice warnings place as well because the
wintry show is coming in here on the
breeze
um readily forming slippery surfaces
Under Foot so it's a bit of a cold one
this morning it's not going to get much
warmer as we go through the day-to-day
temperatures for some will stay a around
about freezing at best we're looking at
three or four degrees the Outlook well I
have to say it's still staying with this
cold spell Friday we've got to watch out
for some rain sleeping slowly just
moving in across parts of Scotland and
then the weekend is when we start to see
a real change so still very cool by
night until this point but we're going
to see a low moving in Saturday into
Sunday and it's Sunday a little bit
worried about a risk of freezing rain as
we see wet and windy weather moving in
could be some freezing rain and even
blizzards across some Northern parts
thanks Kirsty
coming up as nurses take unprecedented
industrial action I'll be speaking to
Pat Cullen the head of the Royal College
of Nursing
foreign
[Music]
the final part of Harry and Megan's
Netflix series is due to be released in
the next uh the latest trailer hints it
claims the palace briefed against the
sussexes to deflect attention from
coverage of other Royals Skies Katie
Spencer joins us now from The Newsroom
and Katie you will soon be sitting in
front of your laptop I am sure but why
not should anyone's care
well look that's the thing 28 million
people or 28 million households tuned in
last week to watch the first three
episodes critically though look most
people said it was a little bit dull a
little bit slow and a little bit boring
they didn't really make any allegations
in the first three episodes will they go
a bit further with these last three
episodes well certainly judging on the
trailer it does look like they certainly
have a bit more to get off of their
chest on the two trailers that we've had
released in the last week we hear from
Megan's lawyer Jenny Affair who says
that she's seen evidence that there was
negative briefing about the couple from
the palace in that same trailer Megan
goes one step further and she claims
that actually the palace were reaching
out to Media organizations and offering
them stories about Megan and Harry in
exchange for taking down removing
stories about other members of the royal
family that they didn't want out there
it also looks as well like Harry's got
some venting to do about his brother he
talks about how the palace were half to
live on behalf of Prince William this is
what they say in the trailer but they
weren't prepared to tell the truth about
him and Megan so it's going to be
interesting uh as you say yeah we've got
a team of six people who are each taking
half an hour so that we can get through
these three episodes uh fairly quickly
and bring you all the breaking news
lines watching it Neil so you don't have
to well unfortunately I've got to
present breakfast daily so I'll have to
give it a swerve anyway Katie many
thanks
uh now we're back to the Health Service
uh nurses of course going on strike
today and the health secretary has said
that he is worried about patient safety
but those striking argue that the NHS
has been under so much pressure recently
patient safety was already at risk and
that is part of the reason that they are
striking let's hear from someone who has
been personally affected by at the
backlog in the service I will join us by
Molly Ellis now her daughter Maya has
just had her fourth NHS operation
canceled it means you can see both of
them joining us now very good morning to
both of you I hope you're well but
obviously not quite as well as as you
might be and Molly Ellis just just tell
us a little bit about this about the
situation uh that Maya finds herself in
I mean four operations potentially have
been canceled is that right yeah that's
correct
um over the past three years she's had
20 bouts of tonsillitis and we were
waiting for two years to get an
appointment to have them out and since
December the 1st last year
um it's now been canceled four times
and when these operations are canceled
how much notice do you get and what
explanation has been given
um no bets
um covet
um twice we've been at the hospital one
time we've been sat on the bed having
been assigned a bed I've been unpacked
you know getting changed into dramas
and then we were told that um it
couldn't go ahead because she was in the
early days of covid what had she been in
the later days of covert it could have
carried on last time we were asked to
sit in a corridor after arriving there
at half seven in the morning we were
there an hour and then somebody finally
came and told us that the operation had
been canceled if they've been able to
Ringers at six o'clock in the morning
when they knew there were no beds
Michael gone to school I could have gone
to work we could have just carried on as
normal
um as I understand it Myers have
recently had what the the 20th about of
tonsillitis I'm just wondering hey Maya
how does it feel when you get the
tonsillitis it must be pretty painful I
remember it well my throat was always
big and swollen
yeah it just feels like my throat's all
blocked up I can't swallow calpol
um ibuprofen all that stuff it's hard
for me to eat and drink and sometimes I
struggle to breathe and it's just
painful and it feels like it feels like
my tonsils have been scraped with a
potato peeler
oh dear that doesn't sound very good and
I suspect I mean on the say again
that massage being normal now now I'm
like 20 times so it is useful I'm used
to it
um Mom I'm I'm wondering where because
obviously you know parents you you want
your child to be well and you know I bet
you your mum goes through you know it
goes through a process in her own head
that she keeps away from you uh uh at
Maya because you know she wants you to
be well who do you who do you think is
responsible for the fact that this
fairly routine operation has been
canceled so many times and this has been
going on for so long
oh without a doubt government
is what the the lack of funding What
specifically is it that they have done
that you feel has led to the situation
you will find yourselves in
I personally think that the government
is running the NHS into the ground with
a view to privatizing we get
um this is why they're not
giving the nurses money uh that they so
rightly deserve having taken pretty much
a 32 I think it is real-time pay cut in
the last 20 years there's nurses using
food banks there's nurses paying 300
pounds in parking just to do their job
it's so wrong
and so you had 100 I would say so it
sounds like Molly Ellis behind the
nurses and they're at strike action
today absolutely absolutely yeah
good uh Maya I thought you saw someone
sneaking in a cat there into shorts uh
is that sitting on your lap is that a
cat you held up there yeah
his name is
lovely well look I I it sounds to me
like you've probably been a very good
girl uh this year Maya so it's a look at
I think Santa will have to be a good
team this year um I'll keep my fingers
crossed I'll keep my fingers crossed
then Molly let's see you get that uh
operation uh just as soon as I can so
much
in January so fingers crossed brilliant
I'll keep my fingers crossed and you
guys have a lovely Christmas when it
comes okay
me too thank you very much thank you
uh well let's just actually head just
across uh the Thames from our studio
here in Westminster uh to the picket
line at St Thomas Hospital in London
will be joined by Pat Cullen head of the
RCN Royal College of Nursing pack good
to good to see you this morning I don't
know whether you were able to hear some
of what we were discussing uh with our
two previous guests they were making the
point that these operations and
cancellations predate uh the the
possibility of strike action uh by the
nurses they're in support of you I mean
what level of popular does support do
you actually think nurses have today
I think the public are very sensible
people and the public if anything the
government should take a leaf out of
their book the public absolutely
understand why nurses are doing this
today standing out in the cold this
morning put out on the cold by this
government with the doors shut on them
it's a tragic day this is a tragic day
for nursing it's a tragic day for those
patients that you've just heard and
speak this morning and it's a tragic day
for the NHS the NHS has been run down by
this government and left in a crisis
what we're trying to do today is to
actually save our energy and NHS and
every single solitary patient that's
waiting on those waiting lists seven
million plus we are doing this for you
today we're going to try and address
those 50 000 vegan posts in England
alone and the only way that we're going
to do it is by by ensuring that our
nurses have a decent wage and that we
can retain them in the Health Service to
look after people you've just spoken to
and actually recruit more brilliant
nurses into the Health Service
can we just be absolutely clear as to
what you would have need to seen from
the government to to pause the strikes
not to call them off but to pause the
strike for today I mean you've said that
they could be positive if Steve Barkley
had simply come to the table and talked
about pay with you is that accurate
absolutely I've been joined last week
full of Hope and to Steve Barclay's
office after he called me there and
there was a lot of optimism around and
in fact hundreds of messages from the
nurses saying um as I said we'll strike
snow be averted because no nurse wants
to be able to do to have to do this
today and we got in that room and it
became abundantly clear that Steve
Bartley wanted to talk about anything
but pay
um and I did a lot of the talking there
wasn't a single Brown Penny additional
Brown Penny put on the table for our
nursing staff he closed us books and he
walked away and he turned us back on
nursing and he turned us back on
patience
I I spoke this morning just a few
minutes ago in fact um with the health
Minister Maria Caulfield who as I
understand it you actually know and you
you know well and and she said look 19.2
is just impossible now I understand the
logic of the request I understand the
sums that led to the 19.2 uh Demand by
the RCN I just wonder whether or not you
you know think that was potentially a
mistake because whilst I can see the
logic in the position I'm not sure that
the RCN sees the politics of asking for
you know essentially a 20 pay rise
well look
um I respect Maria as a nurse and
indeeda is one of our members but her
and me will part company in what she
said about the 19
nurses pay has been eroded now for a
decade by 20 we're asking for that money
to be put back into nurses Pockets so
that we can make sure that they stay in
the Health Service they're not being
grade A they're not asking for anything
more they're asking for the money that
this government took out of their pay to
be put back in so I don't think it is um
excessive at all if we want to address
the 50 000 bacon posts that we've got if
we want to retain the nurses that we've
got in hospitals like this today and
stop them walking away to have to work
in supermarkets and another retail then
we have to ensure that they get a decent
wage we have to stop this making making
nurses pushing nurses to have to go to
food banks to wait till their patients
eat so that then they can eat what's
left over what a way to treat this
profession
why though did the Royal College of
Nursing reject calls to provide cancer
surgery today I mean again this was a
point made by the minister there are any
number of hospitals up and down the
country today that won't be carrying out
you know urgent cancer surgeries they
can remove tumors that can extend life
that can perhaps even save life that
that wasn't something that you felt that
you could do today why
it's actually inaccurate
well damn Kelly's letter to me was she
obviously hadn't got caught up at that
stage the very day before we actually
had Exempted or made sure that
urgent Cancer Care still continues today
as Does chemotherapy that was exactly
what we did the day before and any other
individual case
urgent care that needs to be done today
we will rely on the clinicians that
knows best at local level to come to us
when we are embedded within your trust
today and we will make sure that those
Services continue we've had weeks and
weeks now where we've talked to the
employers and we have absolutely made
sure that urgent Cancer Care continues
today including chemotherapy with
ensured dialysis continue and many other
services insulin to our patients in the
community and also as a result of the
strep a issues that arose this last
couple of weeks we also made sure that
pediatric a e Services continue today
there is nothing Reckless about nursing
there is nothing Reckless about this
strike we've made sure that there's no
additional risk caused to our patients
today over and above the risk that this
government has put on our patients year
on year by reading the nurse's pay
packets by ensuring that we have nothing
but vacancies right throughout our
system so this lies straight and fairly
at the government store not at the door
of those nurses that are standing out on
picket lines today losing a day there's
pay speaking up for their patients and
speaking up for the profession sure but
in sticking absolutely rigidly during
this conversation to to Europe request
for a 19.2 percent pay rise aren't you
in the RCN being being just as
belligerent as Steve Barclay saying he
will go no further than the independent
peer review offer I mean for a
negotiation to happen there has to be
movement on both sides and I understand
your position that you know you want to
hear from the government first that they
are willing to move before you move but
perhaps you could take the first step
no I don't accept that the Royal College
of Nursing is being belligerent I went
down in good faith to his office last
week sat at his table and waited with
optimism for a half an hour for him to
come in and meet with me and when he
came in he made it very clear that pay
was not going to be on the table not a
single extra Brown penny for those
brilliant nurses that you see here today
I've said to him time and time again
please get into a room with me I will
set my case on the table he can do the
same with his and I'm sure at some point
we will come to an agreement just as we
did with the first minister in Scotland
and then we will put it to the 320 000
members that give me my mandate for
today sure this is an agreement me Arjun
strike this is the this is the 320
000 nurses that voted in this ballot you
cannot ignore 320
000 nursing voices I would say to him he
will ignore those people are as Peril
because we are out today for our
patients and for the profession sorry to
interrupt but this is a significant
point but you you made reference to
Scotland there but of course the offer
that is on the table is 7.5 which is
significantly less than the 19.2 that
you're asking for can I take it then
from what you have just said that the
19.2 figure is not set in stone that you
are willing to move and that you are
willing to move pretty significantly in
fact to a round of strikes which we now
expect to be lasting into January
what I would say to the Secretary of
State today is be respectful get into a
room with me and start to talk to me
don't expect me to have to negotiate on
the airwaves at least at least get into
your room I think that's the least you
can do for those 320 000 nurses is to
let me have their voice in that room
with him and for him to listen
Pat Cullen great to have you on the
program this morning do stay warm out
there on the on the picket line I know
it's very very cold just across the
river thanks
uh let's stick then uh with uh the day's
nursing strike uh let's speak now to
saffron corduroy the interim chief
executive of NHS providers uh who joins
us now saffron great to have you on the
program just just give us an idea of the
the contingency measures that will have
had to be put in place today to try and
ensure that that we understand that
plenty of patients will be affected but
we do not want to see the worst of the
negative outcomes that you could imagine
yeah absolutely well a huge amount of
planning as you would expect from the
NHS has gone into managing the the
strike action today and I think it's
really important that that viewers
realize that that trust leaders are here
to provide
um Safe Care
for anyone who needs it in an emergency
situation and those who may be affected
by strike action will already have been
notified whether their procedure or
operation may have been canceled because
we are expecting some significant
disruption but what I would remind
people is that the NHS is is very well
practiced at dealing with levels of
disruption levels of emergency planning
and and that's what they've put in place
measures to make sure that Safe Care is
delivered as far as possible but what we
would say is that things will be
different today things will be altered
people will have found that that they
have appointments canceled in certain
areas or that if they're coming into a e
departments that they may well have to
wait for a long time
saffron maybe you can clear something up
for me I read a couple of reports this
morning that there were negotiations
ongoing between nursing leaders and
individual trusts kind of almost up to
the 11th Hour in terms of which Services
would retain uh nursing staff how true
is that sorry just just first and
foremost
so
I don't have details of the
I know that
happen is that as we have seen we've got
the national derogation so the
exemptions from Strike actions but also
there is there is the option for trust
leaders to negotiate locally with local
strike committees to um see what they
can exempt from the strike action so
that's what will be happening and of
course it's it's right that trust
leaders push to see as much as possible
um Exempted from from the strike action
so that they can continue to run their
services and look at what is being
offered across particular areas across
particular regions so trust leaders are
doing what what they can within their
powers to make sure that they are are
managing their services as effectively
as possible where do we think the pinch
points will be where where will be those
parts of the Health Service that
experience the greatest disruption to me
I think I think that we are going to see
significant disruption in accident and
emergency departments and what we would
say to the public is of course if you
are in an emergency situation a life and
limited situation then you must of
course turn up an a e Department because
they are there to help you but as ever
we would ask the public to think really
carefully about when they do use
Emergency Services versus
using the 111 service or using a
pharmacy if they have a minor condition
or talking to their GP because we know
that accident and emergency should be
there for those life-threatening life or
altering situations rather than being
used
um as as you know turning up for
treatment that could equally be
delivered elsewhere
and in the past I believe that you have
actually supported the idea of the
military part of the army coming in and
supporting services while strikes go on
um is that the case I mean are we
actually seeing a military presence
within the health service today to what
extent
I think what we have seen I think other
than saying we support them in the movie
we know sorry of course excuse my
paraphrasiology no no I mean
Dean is the military have in in previous
situations where we we have needed them
they have played a supporting role and I
think that's what we need to remember so
during covid the logistics of the
military in in setting up the
Nightingale hospitals was invaluable and
the the
um Staffing supplied by the military to
help with vaccinations in vaccination
centers during covid was invaluable but
I think it's fair to say that the
military will be paying a role to
support the NHS rather than replacing
the NHS we know for example that they
don't have the the right privileges to
be able to
um Drive Blue Light Vehicles during an
emergency for example so what we're
talking about here is is supporting
roles rather than replacing roles but we
know that they are called on in in
situations like this where where
additional Personnel are needed
do you see a way through this strike and
we're expecting another one in December
and there's the potential of more in
January when we're confronted with the
the immovable object of the health
secretary and the immovable object of
the Royal College of Nursing
I think it's absolutely
absent we see
we see the the
State and
the table and have the conversations and
have the conversations across the board
about pay terms and conditions and each
understanding each other's point of view
about what you know what the what the
public purse is but also what the
conditions are genuinely like across the
NHS I mean it's fair to say as an
organization representing trust leaders
we have stress for a significant period
of time that we need a better plan for
the workforce across the NHS there are
133 000 vacancies in the NHS we know
that absence levels are are particularly
high and we know that right now the cost
of living is meaning that that the pay
is going less far than it has before so
we've got to remember that there are
severe pressures out there but we also
have to remember that in terms of of the
NHS and the public budget we know that
things the economic situation is
incredibly tight but what we want to see
is is people coming round the table in
order to have that conversation because
trust leaders support their staff
whether they're Strikers
we've only got 30 seconds we've only got
30 seconds on programming I really don't
want to put words into your mouth but
would a significant pay rise from nurses
make it easier for you to recruit people
to to hospitals and fill those gaps
we absolutely know that that pay is one
of the Chris
actors in recruiting and deed retaining
staff across the NHS that's that's a
simple fact it's not the only Factor but
it is a major factor particular
particularly with inflation going
through the roof as it is at the moment
chef and quarterly I'm afraid we have
literally six seconds left in the
program so thank you very much for your
time really appreciate your input
thank you
[Music]